- I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE ONE OF YOU
SHOW UP TO COLLEGE GAME DAY
WITH A SIGN THAT SAYS
KIFFIN'S KRIMSON KORNER,
YOU HILLBILLIES.
- NOT THAT FUNNY.
- HE SAID, "ASK HIM IF HE KNOWS
THE HOMETOWN HILLBILLY."
- ONE OF HIS STAR STUDENTS
IS NONE OTHER THAN HEAD COACH
KYLE WHITTINGHAM.
- OH, HE'S MAD AT COACH KIFFIN.
- LOOKED LIKE THERE WERE
SOME ARGUMENTS
BETWEEN YOURSELF AND LANE
ON THE SIDELINES.
- THERE'S NO ARGUMENTS.
THOSE ARE CALLED ASS-CHEWINGS.
I MEAN...
- IF YOU NEED TO SCOLD
YOUR OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR
AFTER A 30-POINT WIN, YOU NEED
TO REEXAMINE YOUR LIFE.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS SINCE WE'VE
CHECKED IN ON
ALABAMA'S NUMBER ONE PUBLIC
ACCESS CALL-IN SHOW,
AND SINCE THEN, OL' LANE HAS
TRADED IN HIS WEDDING RING
FOR A CHAMPIONSHIP RING.
TURNS OUT HE'S AS BAD AT BEING
A HUSBAND
AS HE IS AT BEING A HEAD COACH.
[LAUGHS]
WE'RE BACK AGAIN WITH TRIPLE K.
YOU'LL NOTICE A LITTLE ADDITION
TO THE TROPHY CASE THIS TIME.
ALSO, THANKS TO MY LOVELY
NOW EX-WIFE
FOR BEING HERE AND LETTING ME
USE MY OLD PHONE.
LET'S TAKE SOME CALLS.
- HEY, COACH.
IT'S SARAH FROM THE BAR
AND THEN THE BACK OF THAT UBER
AND THEN THE COT IN YOUR OFFICE
LAST NIGHT.
ANYWAY, YOU LEFT ONE OF YOUR
VISORS AT MY PLACE,
AND YOU STILL OWE ME FOR YOUR
HALF OF THE MORNING AFTER PILL.
- SORRY ABOUT THAT, GUYS.
LEILA JUST NEEDED TO BLOW OFF
A LITTLE STEAM.
NEXT CALLER.
- LOOKS LIKE ALL YOUR STUFF
GOT DESTROYED.
I GUESS NOW YOU KNOW
HOW IT FEELS
TO BE A PLAYER
TRYING TO TRANSFER
OUT OF YOUR DIRTY PROGRAM, YOU
PETTY BACK-STABBING [BLEEP].
- KEEP IT LANE AND SIMPLE.
NEXT CALLER.
- HEY, COACH.
THIS IS MORE OF AN XS AND OS
QUESTION.
- OKAY.
- IF I BANG YOUR EX-WIFE,
YOU THINK I'LL SEE HER O FACE?
I PRAY THE NEXT TORNADO
FINISHES YOU OFF, PRICK.
LANE IS A DUMB NAME.
- NEXT CALLER.
YOU'RE DOWN ON LANE STREET.
- LANE, IT'S YOUR BUDDY
STEVE SARKASIAN.
- HEY, SARK.
SOUND A LITTLE INTOXICATED.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE DRINKING, RIGHT?
- SHOUT OUT TO BAMA FOR HIRING
THE PAC-12 SLOPPY SECONDS.
[BLEEP] ROLL [BLEEP] TIDE.
HEY, SPEAKING
OF SLOPPY SECONDS,
HOW ABOUT THAT HOT BLONDE PILE
OF SEX YOU COULDN'T KEEP HAPPY?
I WANT TO PEE ON YOU, LEILA.
- HE'S JUST TIRED.
THE LANE IS LEAVING
THE STATION.
NEXT CALLER.
- CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR RAISE, COACH.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU MEAN "OUR RAISE."
- YOU GONNA USE THAT AS HUSH
MONEY FOR THE COLLEGE SLUTS
YOU KNOCK UP,
OR JUST BLOW IT ALL
GETTING YOUR ASSHOLE BLEACHED,
YOU EFFEMINATE
WEST COACH TWINK?
NICE KHAKIS, FRUIT!
- YEAH, I GOT A QUESTION
ABOUT BALL CONTROL.
WHY CAN'T YOU CONTROL
YOUR BALLS
AND STOP TRYING TO [BLEEP]
EVERY BUCKTOOTH
WHITE POWER WHORE AT BAMA?
GO DOGS.
- LANE, I WAS WONDERING,
ARE THERE ANY ACTUAL PLAYS
ON THAT CARD,
OR DO YOU JUST USE IT TO HIDE
YOUR DOUGHY BABY FACE,
YOU COCKY [BLEEP]?
GO BUCKEYES.
- WHAT'S BEEN YOUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE AT ALABAMA?
JUST IN SEC DEFENSES
OR CONVINCING COLLEGE GIRLS
YOU'RE A 41-YEAR-OLD UNDERGRAD
NAMED JOEY FRESHWATER?
GO FAIL AS A HEAD COACH
IN THE BIG TEN, QUEER.
TRUMP 2016!
- ARE THERE ANY REAL CALLERS
OUT THERE?
- HEY, LANE.
DO YOU MISS BEING A HEAD COACH,
OR DO YOU PREFER THE EXCITEMENT
OF SABAN YELLING AT YOU LIKE
A CHILD ON NATIONAL TV?
ALL RIGHT, WELL, FRENCH KISS
YOUR DAD FOR ME, DICK FACE.
- QUICK QUESTION,
WHAT FEELS BETTER,
WHEN NICK SABAN
CHEWS OUT YOUR ASSHOLE
OR WHEN HIS DAUGHTER
FINGERS IT?
- I WILL FIND YOU!
- THROW YOURSELF INTO ONCOMING
TRAFFIC, YOU TRADER ASS--
- COME ON, GUYS.
CAN WE PLEASE TRY
TO CLEAN IT UP?
- NICE TITS, BITCH.
- ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR FROM
ONE OF OUR REGULAR CALLERS.
- HEY, WHY YOU'RE UP,
WHY DON'T YOU HANG YOURSELF
WITH THAT TOO-LONG PHONE CORD?
RUN ANOTHER BUBBLE SCREEN,
YOU UNORIGINAL--
- I WAS WONDERING,
DO THE BOOSTERS GIVE MONEY
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU'LL [BLEEP]
THEIR GROSS WIVES
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO?
- Y'ALL NEED TO STAY
IN YOUR LANE.
- HEY, LANE.
JERRY JONES HERE.
I FINALLY FIRED JASON GARRETT.
I WANT TO MAKE YOU THE NEXT
HEAD COACH OF THE COWBOYS.
HOW QUICK CAN YOU GET
TO DALLAS?
- OH, THANK YOU, MR. JONES.
I'M ALREADY PACKED.
THIS IS PERFECT.
- JUST KIDDING.
IT'S ME, SARK AGAIN.
BARTENDER, A JACK AND COKE
TO GO, PLEASE.
HEY, BUT SERIOUSLY, I HEARD
THEY'RE REPLACING YOU
WITH LES MILES.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR THAT FROM ME.
- SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT
HIS MORALS,
THE MAN IS STILL GORGEOUS
TO LOOK AT.